hey guys how's it going it's currently
242 a.m. when I'm recording this I woke
up and had some thoughts about you know
how far we've come how far I've come
I just wrote something on Facebook
that's important to me and I decided
that it's important for me to talk to
you guys because I don't say thank you
enough I actually thank you a lot but I
don't say I don't say why I'm grateful
enough I for those of you don't know or
those of you who are new to my channel
just thank you for deciding that my
channel was worth your time but III want
you to know that although I try to make
the best videos I can I try to make the
most amazing incredibly funny and
totally clever videos that I can and I
love doing it there's a reason why I'm
here and there's a reason why I'm doing
this end I'm not just you know some guy
yelling into a camera alone in his room
the weirdo down the hall as my neighbors
probably know me as I'm a person I'm a
real person and you know I look back on
how far I've come
especially when I started because I was
just thinking about it and I had
absolutely nothing when I was starting
out and you know I was in one of the
lowest points in my life if you don't
know about me you know
there's some links in the description
about my draw my life telling you where
I came from and you know
the road getting from there to here and
is really interesting to see especially
when I look back on it you know early in
the morning or late at night depending
on how you want to look at it but I just
wanted to say thank you so much for
supporting me in my efforts in
supporting what I believe in because I
don't believe in anything more than I do
in this community and and I want you
guys to know how important it is to me
and how important it is for you guys to
know that I believe in more than just
playing games I love playing games don't
get me wrong I've been playing games
pretty much my whole life and it's just
super super cool to be able to do that
as a job but I recognize that I have
this weird responsibility to you guys
where I'm in this position where so many
people are looking at me and so many
people are judging what I do and so many
people are looking to me for guidance
and I have an obligation to fulfill that
and I have an obligation to tell you
guys that you can literally do anything
it's not hyperbole when I say that it's
not just me spouting nonsense it's
absolutely true because when I started I
had nothing I was in crushing debt at
medical bills I just came out of a
surgery that changed my life and you
know I I had literally nothing I sold my
possessions just be able to do this I
sold you know my xbox couch laptop I was
debating selling my own plasma just to
be able to do it and Here I am now and I
just always have to make sure that I
thank you guys for literally changing my
life and this may seem weird or out of
character to some of you but this is how
I always am and how I always have been
you know I'm always so grateful for the
opportunities that have been given
and I'm always so grateful for the
things that you've done for me and even
though I'm recording this late at night
I had to get the words out and I had to
get the worst to you guys yeah yeah you
you can do literally anything it's it's
entirely plausible that you can if if
someone like me can come so far we're
such an amazing community to rally
around me you know you guys can do so
much more because I firmly truly believe
in you everything that I say I mean with
every fiber of my being I believe in you
and I know that together we can do some
of the most amazing things to change the
world this community has gotten so big
and so powerful in the YouTube community
as a whole that it's unreal to think
about but it's something I'm so
incredibly proud of I'm so incredibly
proud of the fact that you guys stand
strong for what you believe in and
you're your representative in this huge
new emerging community you are a beacon
for them to look up to yeah you can
inspire so many I mean you guys inspire
me to keep going every day and you know
I I didn't really have a direction when
I turn this camera on and I started
talking but if I were to leave with
anything I'll just say that you guys can
do so much more
it is I hope it doesn't seem wrong of me
to expect a lot from you but it's just
cuz I've already seen what you can do so
far then I would be wrong of me not to
push you in the right direction so just
thank you guys so much for taking the
time to think that a guy shouting into a
camera is worth your time and just know
that I'll never be able to repay what
you've done for me but you can still
inspire others and continue to do great
work you know it's always going to
matter no matter what it's that matter
twice about three times now so just
thank you guys so much if you want to
check out more about me if you're new to
the channel I want you guys to know more
about me I've links and videos in the
description where you can see where I've
come from where I talk about you know my
past and what I've done so just
seriously thank you guys so much for
your support every day and you know I
just sometimes have to reflect and use
that as motivation and justification to
keep moving forward because two and a
half years I've been doing this all day
every day it's the only thing I've cared
about so far in the last two and half
years and it's a big thing to care about
so it's nice to be able to keep going
so I the way that's enough rambling for
me you get a lot of rambling for me as a
enough as it is just seriously thank you
guys so much for everything as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye